hello everyone and welcome to a most
impressive game that happened yesterday
in round six of this year's shaja
Masters it is Indian Grandmaster Molly
hartakian versus a Ukrainian Grandmaster
Vitaly bernardsky and it's a game where
uh well obviously if it's a miniature in
modern times miniature is considered a
game that lasts no more than 30 moves
often less than 30 moves and it's hard
to pinpoint where black actually made a
mistake here so as a lot of you guys
have suggested this one let's check it
out and this is not the first time we've
checked out a game by Mr Molly kartikin
here uh there's a brilliant game that we
already covered by him at least one uh
that you guys I'm sure have seen but
just in case you haven't will be the
first link in the description below so
that being said let's check out this and
what uh what really happened so mooli
has the white pieces and he opens with
Ponte E4 with Ponte E6 the French
defense is on the board uh D4 D5 and for
those of you who are uh thinking it no I
I'm not just showing this because uh
it's the French defense Knight the D2 uh
the tarash variation we have Pawn to C5
and now Knight G2 F3 we have a trade in
the center captures captures on D4
Knight to F6 going after the E4 pawn and
now e captures and D5 so a lot of
captures but this is the uh current
theory of this line Knight the two to F3
and now Bishop to B4 with check and now
it will be a terrible mistake to play C3
here because if you play this the Knight
captures on C3 is close to winning for
black if not outright winning the
problem is after you trade here Bishop
captures on C3 uh it comes with chicken
you might be thinking okay I will gladly
give up The Rook for two pieces no black
will just take the Knight on D4 and then
after the Knight captures Queen captures
on D4 and black now has um uh one two
pawns and there's not all that much that
white has to show for let's say Rook to
C1 goes after the bishop black will just
Castle here and black is just much much
better here so instead after Bishop to
B4 check Bishop to D Q this is still
well known Theory and here there are a
couple of moves that reach this position
uh Bishop to C5 a fairly rare move and
now there is a game where C3 was played
also night the B3 is a normal but here
we have Bishop to B5 check and it is now
as of move 9 that we have a completely
new game so let's see how Italy uh
replies to this he goes uh Bishop to D7
blocks check Bishop captures with check
Knight captures and now both players
Castle so castles castles and here
morally plays Queen to E2 he develops
the queen connects the Rooks and is
ready to bring the Rooks into the game
we have Bishop captures on D4 uh might
seem like an uh like an odd move but uh
here uh vital is saying that the knights
are are stronger than uh the bishop here
and you might consider Queen the B6 just
putting pressure on the Knight and going
after that video Pawn but he decides to
trade first captures captures and now
Queen to B6 attacking the Knight and the
B2 Pawn Knights the B3 and now Rook F3
C8 putting pressure on the C2 Pawn so
Pawn to C4 attacking the Knight and not
Knight back to E7 and here we have
Bishop to C3 placing the bishop on this
diagonal and saying that I might be
interesting interested in in a quick
Checkmate here so Knight to F5 and now
Rook after D1 putting pressure on the
undefended Knight on D7 so Queen to C7
defending and also putting pressure on
that C4 pawn and now just Knights the D4
and now of course the problem is you
don't have time for Queen captures and
C4 uh because the Knight Will capture an
F5 and then the Knight and D7 will be
hanging so instead we have Knight
captures on D4 Rook counters and D4 sort
of a free rook lift for white here
Knights the f8 now preparing to bring
the Knight to G6 because you know that
there will be a lot of pressure along
the G file uh Rook to G4 and now Knights
the G6 and of course the pawn to H4 you
are ready to play H5 kick away tonight
and win the game so this is still all
perfectly fine for black we have Queen
to C5 now stopping Pawn to H5 and now
Rook to G3 a very tricky move that
invites black the captran C4 and even
though a capturing on C4 is the best
move for black is just very hard to
decide to actually play this because you
know that H5 is coming once everything
gets traded off to give you an example
if Queen captures on C4 and uh be
mindful this is the strongest move for
black queen characters Rook captures
Pawn to H5 kicks away the Knight and
once the Knight moves Rook cap G7 with
check King f8 now even H6 you're gonna
capture an H7 next and it just looks
really really bad for example Knight to
F5 attacks The Rook okay we're gonna
capture on H7 now you're threatening to
win The Rook on A8 so King D7 has to be
played now Rook to C1 with the idea of
maybe bishop t7 check to win the rook
and although this looks very Bleak for
black you you can actually play Knight
to D4 you stop in any checks and now
even the threaten Knight to E2 and the
game continues lets the king to F uh one
and only now only now upon the E5 but in
the game after this Rook to G3 move
Vitale played Pawn to E5 right away and
this allows the white to continue the
attack very fiercely so Ponte H5 chases
away the Knight Knight the four attacks
the queen and queen to G4 now threatens
Checkmate on G7 with Pawn to G6 and now
how do you continue this and this is a
very important moment for yeah morally
here and it's a very important moment in
the life of every attacker or everyone
that the wishes to consider themselves
an attacker the point is you could
capture you could also try maybe H6
maybe you can wiggle uh the queen all
the way to F6 and then deliver Queen to
G7 Checkmate it's very unlikely because
the black queen has access to the f8
square but here is a mark of a true
attacker bring another piece into the
attack Rook 8 to E1 it also comes with
Tempo now the E5 Pawn is hanging and all
of these threats remain with you having
an extra rook in the attack so always be
mindful of that and now how can black
defend this it's it looks like a really
bad position and perhaps maybe an engine
would hold this I'm going to show you a
line that sort of allows black to defend
which goes Rook to E8 I mean it's uh it
looks like a move that you should play
because it just defends the pawn but now
let's say h captures Knight captures and
G6 and pawn to B4 always spawn to B4 I
mean I I don't think we even need to
discuss this anymore let's say queen to
C6 and now Queen to H5 now you are
threatening the uh the gobble up the E5
pawn and now after let's say Rook 838
you will just play Rook the H3 and it
seems like okay you you can just resign
this but perhaps it is possible to
defend Queen to F6 you allow Queen
captures on H7 checking to f8 and black
uh still is hanging on whether black can
survive the game it's hard to say but uh
you know there's no clear way to win
this however after Rook to E1 uh here uh
Vitali played Pawn to F6 and sometimes I
know Pont F6 is the strongest move there
even uh were moments where I ask you
guys to pause the video and find the
absolute best move for black and
sometimes the answer is Pawn to F6 but
this is not one such occasion so here
Pawn to F6 was played H characters and
G6 H captors and G6 and now uh this is
move 26 feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Morely uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well uh move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
the E4 so congratulations to everyone
who found that but also congratulations
to everyone who found Bishop to D2 or
Rook to F3 the idea is basically the
same you want to give up any of your
pieces for this Knight on F4 that pretty
much holds Black's position together
Knight the E4 is the is the most forcing
line so this is what morally played now
he's just gonna capture the Knight here
and there's not all that much you can do
here uh King to f8 was played trying to
get off that g file but it doesn't
matter now you don't even have to play
even though Rook captures an F4 is
winning uh Queen to H4 with Pawn to G5
attacking the queen and now just Queen
to H6 with the check and he was in this
position on move 29 that Vitaly
bernardsky resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the black
king is in check and it really doesn't
matter what you play uh the the the
White Queen has not fully infiltrated
let's say you play Queen to F7 no not
just will captures an F4 and how do you
defend if you capture with this Pawn
then The Rook comes into the game if you
capture with this Pawn then the F6 Pawn
just gets gobbled up by the queen and
then you get checkmated for example
captures Queen captures and F6 King goes
here Rook to H3 and now of course uh
there's no uh there's no escaping
striking to D7 first Rook the H7 check
now that King has to go back and that's
it so you're gonna play King to E8 even
Queen to E6 with check uh King to f8 and
now Rook to h8 Checkmate oh this is only
one of the one of the possibilities but
pretty much everything else you do also
ends in Checkmate so no no real point in
continuing and look at those pawns this
Pawn on E5 this pawn and G5 of course uh
yeah you cannot defend this so it's hard
to say uh it's not really hard to say
where black went wrong because of course
F6 is the the final losing move by black
but you could also say that here in this
position where black played fonte E5
instead of going for that weird tricky
line that we've discussed first you
capture then you allow H5 then you allow
root captures on G7 and then only block
the bishop after all that is said and
done with Ponte E5 and maybe you know
you you continue fighting uh but yeah E5
definitely a sub optimal move and then
with Pawn to F6 uh just uh you know uh
you just get completely destroyed uh so
yeah uh not not a bad game by either of
them uh Vitaly also played a great game
but uh you know one sub-optimal move and
one mistake is more than enough for a
player of umulus caliber and he
definitely uh made a use of his uh
opportunity their roles here uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
like I said if you are interested in
this do check out I believe we could
even consider it more this Immortal game
will be the first link in the
description below so do check that out
as well I would like to thank David
Kimura am the reason Enthusiast group
golfsoftware.com and Gary Shaw for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on
everything else that happening in the
Chess World and of course the wonderful
suggestions that you guys send over my
way so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day